what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we have a ton
of news about the upcoming new
Spider-Man film Spider-Man 4 with Tom
Holland today we have some news about
the plot of the film news about
production of the film and a reported
release date we also do have some news
about the villains of Spider-Man 4 not
just one villain but many and yes it
does look like it might cross over a
tiny bit with Spider-Man across the
spider-verse so a ton to dive into today
and if you want to stay up to date on
Spider-Man 4 be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification Bell also if you
want to enter our giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox series X A PS5 some
Marvel Legends items or some DC items
all you gotta do subscribe and leave a
comment on our videos the winner gets to
pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month now let's first
start out by talking about the
production of the film because right now
since the strikes are going on
everything is kind of halted but before
the strikes happened it was confirmed
that Sony and Marvel Studios had already
begun meeting to discuss what was going
to happen with Spider-Man 4 and Tom
Holland was a part of those meetings as
well he even confirmed this himself so
we know that Spider-Man 4 was about to
get going with the pre-production in
fact it's already begun however they
just had to pause it because of the
strikes that are happening but if it
doesn't get delayed by too much because
of the strikes we do know that it should
be coming out before Secret Wars and
this is according to my time to shine
hello and my time to shine hello has
also stated that Spider-Man 4 currently
has a release date for August 28th of
2025. that isn't too long from now which
is very exciting however and
unfortunately things can and probably
will get delayed due to the strikes if
the studios can't come to an agreement
the strikes are going to continue
however if they work out a deal within a
month or so they could probably stay
true to this release date and of course
we'll update you if anything happens but
it's clear that it's very important for
Spider-Man 4 to come out before Avengers
Secret Wars which makes sense because
that is going to be the ending of not
only phase six but of the Multiverse
Saga in general now according to The
Insider can we get some toast Spider-Man
4 is kind of going to be somewhat of a
sequel to Hawkeye now that doesn't mean
that Hawkeye is going to appear in the
film or that okay Bishop is going to
appear in the film as well but what
they're really talking about is Kingpin
Kingpin is going to be one of the
villains in Spider-Man 4 and this is
most likely what The Insider is
referring to when they say it's going to
be kind of a sequel to Hawkeye in fact
from what we've heard Kingpin is going
to try to run for mayor of New York City
so Kingpin is going to be a pretty
prominent player for a few different
projects including Spider-Man 4 the echo
series and of course the Daredevil
Series so for those who have been kind
of upset lately with the lack of
connectivity of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe it's about to come back in a
pretty big way and not with just these
projects but with a lot of other
projects as well now before we talk
about the other villains there is going
to be somewhat of a plot point that I
think is going to be very interesting
and this is going to pick up right after
the events of Spider-Man no way home
apparently according to the cosmic
circus Tom Holland could be wearing his
mask for most of the film and that Peter
Parker's personal life could be taking a
back seat temporarily for this film and
of course if you think about what
happened at the end of Spider-Man no way
home Doctor Strange finally doing the
correct spell to erase Peter Parker's
memory from everybody it makes sense
because everybody still remembers who
Spider-Man is they just simply do not
know that Peter Parker is Spider-Man
nobody knows Peter Parker anymore and
that's why they could really just focus
on Spider-Man including Peter Parker he
could finally just take the time to be
Spider-Man he's not going to have a love
interest at least not at first he won't
have his best friend there anymore sadly
Aunt May is not there anymore happy
doesn't know who he is most of the
Avengers don't know who he is we're
still a little unclear about Dr strange
but he really has nobody which is why
there could be a bigger focus on him as
Spider-Man now of course Zendaya is
returning for this film so I'm sure at
some point in time something's going to
happen there and he's going to talk to
her or maybe perhaps try to get the
spell reversed just for her who knows
but the love interest that is MJ will be
in this film now there is another huge
aspect of this film that we're gonna
talk about along with the villains and
that is Miles Morales but first if you
love Spider-Man and you want to learn
more about Spider-Man be sure to check
out my buddies over at
comicbookdirect.com I have created a
website and company that makes comic
book shopping the easiest it can
possibly be they deliver Comics straight
to your door you can get one-off Comics
or you can sign up for an entire run and
get a pretty big discount if you do so
and they'll ship the latest issue right
to your door each week they have the
latest from Marvel if you're trying to
keep up to date with all the recent
projects they have the latest from DC as
well and it's an all-in-one shop for
your Comics everything that you need in
one place you can sign up for a
membership to get free shipping and a
mystery box each month and the next 100
people to sign up get 20 off their first
order using the link in the description
down below so according to The Insider
viewer Anon they have heard that the
plan slash goal for Spider-Man 4 is to
bring Miles Morales into the MCU Peter
would meet him while shaken post no way
home and they'll Bond over the course of
the movie also at the same time the
cosmiccircus.com reported that Donald
Glover will be returning for Spider-Man
4 as well now this is very very
interesting because we just saw Donald
Glover as Prowler and Spider-Man across
the spider-verse in live action form and
it was confirmed that this is indeed the
same Donald Glover the same Prowler from
the MCU and now we have word that he is
going to be returning for Spider-Man 4.
this definitely sets up Miles Morales
because all the way back in Spider-Man
homecoming we met proud Aaron Davis we
met Donald Glover's Aaron Davis who did
specifically say that he has a nephew as
it turns out that wasn't just a clever
little Easter egg but Miles Morales is
actually going to be happening and
little fun fact Donald Glover is
actually why we have Miles Morales he
was the inspiration behind creating
Miles Morales this came from his role in
community where he once wore a
Spider-Man suit which gave the creators
the inspiration to create Miles Morales
now Miles Morales is huge right now due
to the spider-verse franchise so it'll
be awesome to see him live action in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and hopefully
these reports are true and he will be
introduced in Spider-Man 4 and he will
help Peter Parker kind of deal with
everything and kind of be his only
friend after the doctor strange spell
and we do kind of know that Tom Holland
is basically done after this next
Spider-Man trilogy so it does seem like
throughout this Trilogy he'll train
Miles Morales to essentially take over
as Spider-Man when he is eventually gone
now like I'm mentioned there have been
reports of other villains for Spider-Man
4. this report is coming from the cosmic
circus who reports that Kingpin Mr
negative Craven and Scorpion are the
villains of the film and right away I'm
sure some people are thinking what I
thought it does seem like they might be
building a true Sinister Six we almost
got the Sinister Six with Spider-Man no
way home but that's not really what it
was also the same here there may be Four
villains but of course there's only four
not six but they could be building up to
a true Sinister Six perhaps in the next
film or the sixth film now here it does
get a little bit confusing though we
know scorpion has already been in the
MCU since Spider-Man homecoming however
so has vulture and it does seem like
vulture did make the switch over to the
Sony universe and that makes us wonder
about Craven is this going to be Aaron
Taylor Johnson's Craven the hunter who
is about to have his own rated R solo
film or is this going to be a different
Craven the hunter one that is
specifically event for the MCU with a
completely different actor or could it
be a separate Craven with the same actor
this is where he gets a tiny bit
confusing with Sony's plan but knowing
Marvel Studios they're not going to want
too much of a crossover so I'm going to
assume this is going to be a completely
different Crave in the Hunter and will
have a new actor but as far as Mr
negative is concerned he actually fits
quite well with the current story of
Spider-Man you see Mr negative has two
personas to him he has the Mr negative
side who is the chinatown's Kingpin of
crime with the ability to generate black
electrical energy but then you have the
other side of him Martin Lee Martin Lee
is actually the person who opens and
operates Feast where Aunt May worked at
this could be the case in the MCU as
well Martin Lee could be the person who
opened Feast Aunt May could have known
Martin Lee and Peter may go work at
Feast again in honor of Aunt May and he
may meet Martin Lee in the comics both
of them on May and Peter did not know
about Martin Lee's other identity as Mr
negative so I'm assuming it'll kind of
be the same for the MCU as well and it's
unsure right now if these villains are
going to come together in this film or
they'll simply take on Peter one by one
and eventually and ultimately come
together to try and defeat him as part
of a group hopefully fingers crossed the
Sinister Six and hopefully if that does
happen Peter is going to have some help
as well in the form of Miles Morales
perhaps Prowler could even be one of the
members of the Sinister Six miles's
Uncle we'll have to wait and see on that
but so far Spider-Man 4 is looking
pretty good and hopefully if the strikes
end soon they'll get back on track with
the production and we'll get some
official announcements very very soon
maybe even a title but of course if we
hear anything in the meantime we'll be
sure to do an update so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos don't forget to follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching well for
thank you